un appel depuis un téléphone portable
vient de leur apprendre que deux hommes
sont tombés dans une crevasse de la
vallée blanche
ils ont une vague indication sur
l'endroit où cela s'est passé
aucun témoin pour leur donner des
précisions jean françois mercier et le
chef de la mission
son premier souci localiser la crevasse
il est déjà 18h30
ils ont peu de temps pour retrouver les
skieurs l'interlocuteur du téléphone ne
leur a donné aucune indication sur
l'endroit où ils ont une chance de les
retrouver
et puis un énorme coup de chance
il fallait le voir ce ski ne pas le
confondre avec une crevasse
regarde un peu
[Musique]
deuxième indice à côté du ski des traces
de pas qui mène jusqu'à la crevasse
[Musique]
il faut une grande confiance dans le
pilote pour demander à se faire
hélitreuillé à l'intérieur de la
crevasse au moindre écart
c'est la catastrophe
maintenant c'est encore
benoît côté des skis
[Musique]
good ragots il faut que je sache s'il ya
quelqu'un dans ce trou on va essayer de
faire le point sur la croatie on vous
transmettre ouais
o o are you vous parlez français
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous tout va
bien quelqu'un est blessé
[Musique]
ok elles sont approximativement une
vingtaine de mètres sous la surface
donc j'ai besoin du renfort de la
deuxième équipe
jean-françois ne pourrait pas les sortir
tout seul trois autres secouristes vont
venir l'aider à extraire les imprudents
on va déjà voir en bas si on peut en
sortir un rapidement tiens tu prends ça
tu es prêt meute et encore des maths
c'est mathieu il va descendre en premier
ok
sacré saut à près de 20 m un premier
homme avec son casque rouge 2 mètres
plus bas
le blessé sur le dos il est recouvert de
neige et bouge difficilement est-ce
qu'il a mal quelque part où il est juste
bloquer la maladie quesnel et sécurisé
et là il est assis sur un pont de glace
il a la jambe cassée et l'autre est
coincé il a du mal à respirer
tout seul je vais pas réussir à le
sortir julio un deuxième sauveteurs va
rejoindre matthieu dans la crevasse
jean-françois commence à comprendre ce
qui a pu se passer
la trace elle passe une dizaine de
mètres en amont on voit qu'ils ont déjà
eu de la chance ils ont évité un premier
trou ils ont tombé dans le deuxième
puisque moi quand je suis arrivé j'ai
juste vu ses deux skis qui était posée
parallèle juste ici donc on peut
imaginer qu'il ya une première personne
qui a chuté dans la crevasse et que son
collègue est arrivé et est tombé à son
tour
il attend que le mec là il fait beau
chaud il est coincé et celui qui a
vraiment cassé il à côté de moi il va
s'attend lui à la personne du roi il
avait peut-être en bois on a eu pour
thème prend il ce que d'aller plus bas
auquel edf de maths c'est bon il est
prêt à être remonté ok on sort le
valider
ouais ben pouces avec tes pieds ouais
ouais encore tu t'es ramage en voilà
ouais pas les hoquets
à l'aller
[Musique]
pas dragon alléluia
à tanger sécurisé faut quoi
enfin faut vite qu'on puisse redescendre
la corde à l'autre équipe marocaine a
[Musique]
ok
le d'être une jambe cassée mais c'est
celui qui est encore au fond qui semble
le plus mal en point
l'hélicoptère vient récupérer le premier
dans quelques minutes
la nuit sera là on y verra plus rien
alors la paix qu'il est d'or
il est chaud
koné
frappé comme ça
quel appareil
pourquoi
reste le deuxième homme parle à la radio
maths on laissera consorts sortir est au
fond du trou
matt a réussi à accrocher le deuxième
homme à la corde qui est relié au trail
en surface mais au moment où il commence
à le dire et c'est semble-t-il la
chambre qui coince et qu'est ce qui se
passe on voit pas donc on a notre autre
personne qui est blessé donc les deux
secouristes ont du mal à la décoincer le
problème c'est qu'on peut pas envoyer
plus de personnel parce que c'est
beaucoup trop exigu donc les deux gars
sont en train de piocher pour le pour le
dégager au mieux de son âme à glace il
pioche et creuse la glace pendant plus
d'une heure pour le dégager
[Rires]
ouais mais tu veux condescendu commente
il est bon de le tirer et choqué il est
parti pour un voyage en contrat après
trois heures dans la glace la
température de l'homme a beaucoup baissé
il est en hypothermie immédiate
récupération immédiate
ok bon gars ça va est ce que c est ce
que tu entends ça va ça va bien j'ai vu
qu'au pire arrive dans cinq minutes
ok et après on t'emmène
il est 21h30 les deux hommes ont eu une
chance incroyable
si l'un des deux ce qui n'avait pas été
repéré il serait très probablement morts
dans le glacier